all right let's start um with some big
but expected news so i don't have that
much more to say about it than i've
already said because this is exactly
what we've been expecting
um
joe biden's voting rights bill
seems to be dead because democrats have
been unable to change the filibuster
which very clearly became a prerequisite
to really be able to do the voting
rights bill and this is exactly what we
expected so i don't know how much there
is to say but as the associated press
press's reporting voting bill collapses
democrats unable to change filibuster
voting legislation that democrats and
civil rights leaders say is vital to
protecting democracy that's true it is
collapsed when two senators refused to
join their own party in changing senate
rules to overcome a republican
filibuster after a raw emotional debate
who are those two senators well i'm sure
many of you know they are democratic
senator joe manchin and democratic
senator kirsten cinema the outcome
wednesday night says the ap was a
stinging defeat for president biden and
his party coming at the tumultuous close
to his first year in office yeah almost
to the day biden said in a statement
after the vote i am profoundly
disappointed but that he is quote not
deterred and vowed to quote explore
every measure and use every tool at our
disposal to stand up for democracy so
the question now is what can be done via
executive order
to maybe
put in place
some elements of what would have been in
the voting rights bill but mansion and
cinema's
positions on this
not a surprise and the idea of changing
the filibuster remember was to reduce
the threshold
for debating the voting rights bill from
60. when you have 50 democrats and you
need 60 votes you need 10 republicans
this is pretty simple math the idea of
changing the filibuster was the chant to
change the requirement of 60 in order to
do that they needed all 50 democrats
they didn't have them the filibuster
doesn't change and thus there is at this
time no path forward for the voting
rights legislation now i think it's
important
that you know when we talked about
leading into the 2016 election
there were these people uh uh who who
should be really crawling into a hole
and never being heard from again uh in
terms of their opinions who were saying
hillary trump it's not really going to
make a difference it's all it's all kind
of the same
uh if it's not a real progressive i
don't want the person uh it doesn't
really matter
uh and we said well but sir ma'am what
about the supreme court what about all
these different things
look at the supreme court at this point
in time look at all the things look at
the disasters that ended up happening
under donald trump so we've got to
remember that at the same time we have
to remember now
uh that
this is a fundamental
building block of our democracy
republicans have made it clear they've
abandoned policy they've abandoned
convincing people that their ideas are
good they merely want to win on
obstructing democrats
and using
uh
voter suppression
and various um uh other tactics to make
it more difficult to vote to try to win
elections and then if you don't win try
to steal the election that's what they
do now and so when something like this
gets stalled in its tracks hopefully joe
biden can do some of this via executive
order we don't yet know we have to see
but remember these kind of turning
points and one of those was
hillary trump how bad could trump really
be let's send a message let's shake it
up wow what a disastrous four years
we've got to be thinking along those
same lines here
this next story is it's unbelievable and
yet it's predictable because it's
florida
florida
has suspended a public health official a
doctor for encouraging his own staff to
get vaccinated uh it's it's insane and
it's dystopian npr reports florida
department of health confirms dr raul
pino put on leave
for encouraging orange county department
of health employees to get vaccinated
didn't require anybody to get vaccinated
encouraged people to get vaccinated and
he has been suspended the florida
department of health medical director
that oversees areas of orange county
including orlando has been put on leave
for encouraging encouraging his own
staff to get vaccinated
orange county medical director dr raul
pino wrote an email to staff on january
4th
encouraging them to get vaccinated and
boosted for covid in it he wrote quote
i'm having a hard time understanding how
we can be in public health and not
practice it makes perfect sense sensible
down to earth statement
after sending the email he was placed on
administrative leave
in an email to wmfe florida department
of health confirmed he was on leave
because quote the decision to get
vaccinated is a personal choice that
should be free from coercion and
mandates from employers
now encouraging is not demanding
it is not coercion it is not a mandate
it is not offering a consequence if you
fail to do it it's just hey you know
like we're in public health and there's
these vaccines and they're very good at
keeping people alive when they get
covered and we we should really get them
it's kind of weird that we work in
public health and we whoa we people need
to be free from mandates also dystopian
florida department of health says it's
even conducting an inquiry into whether
any laws were broken by sending the
email republican governor ron desantis
has banned vaccine mandates in the
workplace
and the state has seen a surge in
omicron cases
what
what and also remember
that before it became politically
inconvenient to ron desantis ron
desantis was encouraging vaccination
more recently desantis was asked if he's
boosted and he didn't even want to
answer the question
and the encouragement of vaccination has
stopped but when it was a different
political situation when it was trump
made the vaccines and let's go get them
ron desantis had a very different
outlook and at the end of the day ron
desantis is determined to spread covet
as far and wide as possible into the
nooks and crannies of the state of
florida uh and you know what's the if
saying hey guys um since we practice
public health we should actually
practice it and get vaccinated no
mandate no coercion no threat of firing
but we should probably do it
that now is not allowed
uh de facto because he was placed on
administrative leave what's going to be
next you go to the pharmacy hey by the
way uh you're picking up your pills
did you know that we have vaccines
available and they're free to you did
you want to get one have you been
vaccinated whoa that's coercion
pharmacists shouldn't even be allowed to
do that that's the next step
when you say this
action by dr raul pino
deserves a suspension which of course it
doesn't and we'll see whether he is
ultimately fired whether he comes back
with some kind of reprimand whether he
quits or whatever the case may be
all right thirdly today
this is also big news we have a horrible
supreme court right now that that
shouldn't be news but we do
thanks by the way
to donald trump choosing three people
who are now on it
rather than hillary clinton that
that cannot be ignored that's a reality
but that disastrous supreme court
has put a final stop
to donald trump's demands that white
house records
not be provided to the committee
investigating the trump riots this is
good news
cnbc reporting the supreme court has
rejected a trump request to block the
release of records to the january 6th
committee the supreme court rejected a
request from former president trump to
block those records the ruling which
trump cannot appeal
sets the stage for more than 700 pages
of trump white house records to soon be
sent by the national archives to the
committee that's an important detail it
is not now trump who has to release them
it is the national archives that will
release them trump had argued that he
had the authority as a former president
to invoke executive privilege to prevent
the disclosure of the records president
biden has declined to invoke executive
privilege for the records which the
committee wants as part of its probe of
the invasion of the capital by a mob of
trump supporters this is a very very
good decision and it is the correct
decision
notably
the supreme court order the supreme
court decision
was eight to one the one was justice
clarence thomas who dissented and said
now trump should be able to block it
and what is particularly disturbing
about that is that clarence thomas's
wife
cheered the stop the steel rally on
january 6th
that ultimately was one of the primary
inciting factors of those trump riots
and she subsequently apologized to her
husband's law clerks but given clarence
thomas's obvious conflict of interest
here if he had respect for the law he
would recuse himself from anything even
remotely related to the january 6 trump
riots but it is clarence thomas after
all and imagine i mean just think about
that
the wife
of a supreme court justice was cheering
cheering cheering
the event
and the individuals
that
led to
an attempted insurrection
at the country in the country where your
husband is a supreme court justice it's
absolutely stunning stuff
but ginny thomas is maybe something to
focus on uh on a different day that's
the supreme court decision
this appears to be the end i know we say
that all the time with trump and trying
to hide records well this this is it now
and then something else happens by every
reasonable stretch of the imagination
this is a supreme court decision and
this is it
and the records will be provided to the
committee whether they will be made
public
deliberately
or because they will leak or whatever we
do not yet know but that's the supreme
court decision and it is the correct
decision let me know what you think will
we ever see those records you can find
me on twitter at deepakman we're going
to take a very quick break and be right
back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so the david pakman show subreddit has
really been on fire i think we have
close to 34 000 of our viewers and
listeners subscribed uh you can find it
at davidpakman.com
reddit and many interesting discussions
happening every day a few of which i
spotted this morning that i wanted to
highlight
user stone 500 posted my kids school
district in missouri is closed for the
rest of this week
due to staffing and attendance issues i
got a letter from the school system
um essentially there's so many people
sick
that the school had to close and this is
a really important thing i know people
in these situations as well where the
school is open in principle but then so
many people so many teachers are sick
that the school is closed um until they
can find teachers their teachers can
recover from kovid even when we have
this discussion of should schools be
closed or not because of the virus
my preference is for schools to be open
i agree with everybody who says it's
better for kids to be in school in
person who would deny that
the question is by forcing them open
do you really keep them open because if
they're open and 15 of the teachers end
up having to isolate slash quarantine
because they're either exposed or catch
and then you just don't have people you
don't have staff you don't have janitors
whatever and then you close anyway
what did we really gain by having a
couple of chaotic days in school and i'm
hearing from tons of parents who are
saying that this exact thing is going on
when people started going back
two weeks ago one week ago
my thought was
there's no way that this is going to
work in any real way either you're just
going to commit to the schools becoming
super spreader
nodes
or you'll be open a few days and if
you're actually testing and have some
kind of protocol you'll then just be
forced to close and and it's happening
just about everywhere so interesting
that a lot of parents in the audience
are experiencing that and again i think
it's better for the schools to be open
we want them open
it seems like it might have made sense
to do remote maybe two three weeks we
see the omicron wave already coming down
and we'll have those numbers for you
probably early next week the numbers are
looking better and better it probably
made sense to just do remote for a
couple of weeks doesn't sound completely
crazy or or devastating to the students
and it would have prevented this
insanity that's going on now
a really very important post from sw
frame
who said should the democrats try to get
a la carte network tv
in order to reduce the impact of fox
news
fox news is not ad supported not
completely that's true they charge the
cable networks more than other channels
which means all subscribers indirectly
fund the disinformation spewing out of
fox news maybe democrats should get the
cable networks to switch to a la carte
programs i have been talking about this
for years
a ton of these networks
function are viable
channels
through bundling and uh and or through
charging really high fees so when you
pay a hundred bucks for cable you may or
may not know that certain amounts from
that hundred bucks go to specific
channels or groups of channels do you
really think that i'm making this up now
okay but
do you really think
that if imagine that there was a bundle
that's like golf one two and three hgtv
one through four and we you know
whatever i don't even know if these
channels exist imagine that it's like
okay you gotta pay us seven bucks per
subscriber for all seven of those
channels
imagine that those were separated out
and instead you could pay a dollar for
each of those channels do you think that
many people are going to say i want to
pay for hgtv one two three and four of
course not of course not and much the
same way
um if fox news had a different deal
uh where people could say i don't want
fox news and then they can save three
four five bucks i don't know what it is
fox news loses a ton of money and that's
exactly why they don't do it that way so
yes a la carte cable programming is
something i've been talking about for a
really long time it it's there with hbo
we know the technology exists
if you don't want hbo you don't pay for
hbo it's very very simple considered a
premium channel um if it were quite
frankly if it were that way for a lot
more channels all of us would be saving
money and a lot of these channels would
go out of business but yes we that's a
very very good idea lastly
a user
brian crc posted question for trump
rally attendees the trump rally started
up again over the weekend can you name
something new you learned for the rally
and of course the from the rally and of
course the answer is no
uh trump has been doing the same stuff
at the rallies basically since election
day right saying i i won and information
is coming up very soon and the real
insurrection was uh january it was not
january it was november of 2020 and all
this different stuff
they are not there to learn anything new
um they are there to participate in the
cult of personality
and unless we understand that it's going
to be very difficult to prevent
uh it from happening again and it is not
about what he says it is not about
learning anything we need to understand
these people really for what they are
which is quite frankly cult members of a
different sort a political cult um and i
think that that would be a really
interesting quest we've seen people do
interviews of trump supporters at the
rallies
it would be great if someone on the way
out stopped people and said what did you
learn today that you didn't know before
that would be a treasure trove of
fascinating interview material i
encourage someone to do it i don't want
to be caught dead near any of those
rallies particularly because it seems
really difficult to leave
there was video from the rally in
florence arizona over the weekend of
people saying
we were not we're not being allowed to
leave they're saying you need to wait
until the full trump motorcade leaves
and then they were allegedly letting all
the vendors leave and there were people
stuck for hours after the rally imagine
trump's late to every rally
drones on for 90 to 120 minutes
and then you're not even allowed to
leave right away insane la i don't want
to go if someone else wants to go and
ask these people what they've learned i
i totally support it uh but i have no
interest in being there join the
discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit alright i do have another story
today of another one of these
anti-vaxxed unvaccinated people
that has died of covid but this one is
particularly insidious
because of the details this is someone
who wanted to get infected they wanted
the immunity that they believed getting
infected with the virus would give them
and they are now dead
hannah horka a czech singer
is dead
after intentionally getting infected
with covid the bbc uh by ben tobias
reporting on this
a folk singer from uh the czech republic
has died after deliberately catching
covet hannah horika was 57 years old was
unvaccinated posted on social media that
she was recovering after testing
positive and was dead two days later
her son
said she got infected on purpose
when he and his father had the virus so
she could get a recovery pass to access
certain venues
the czech republic reported a record
number of coveted cases yesterday
mr wreck and his father who were both
fully vaccinated both caught coveted
over christmas but he said his mother
decided not to stay away from them
pretend preferring instead to expose
herself
he said she should have isolated for a
week because we tested positive but she
was with us the whole time
proof of vaccination or recent infection
from the virus is required in the czech
republic to go to many venues including
movie theaters bars and cafes his mother
was a member of one of the oldest czech
folk groups assonance she had wanted to
catch covet so there would be fewer
restrictions on her
two days before she died she wrote on
social media she was recovering quote
now there will be a theater sauna a
concert
sunday morning the day she died she said
she was feeling better and got dressed
to go for a walk her back started
hurting she went to lie down in her
bedroom her son says in 10 minutes it
was all over she choked to death
although she was unvaccinated
jan her son stressed his mother didn't
believe in some of the more bizarre
conspiracy theories about covid vaccines
her philosophy was she was more okay
with the idea of catching it than
getting vaccinated not that we would get
microchipped or anything like that
there was no point in trying to discuss
the issue with her as it would get too
emotional instead he hoped that by
telling his story he could convince
others to get vaccinated that's the hope
um
how
scary is it
that she felt good enough to go for a
walk
and ten minutes later was dead that is
absolutely horrifying and we talk about
sympathy
um you know
every one of these situations is
different
but this is someone who not only refused
to get vaccinated
but deliberately got sick she she
deliberately exposed herself to the
virus refused the best protection we
have against serious illness and death
when we have a highly effective and
protective vaccine
where is this on the spectrum of
sympathy i i don't know
and there's a case to be made that big
picture the recovery passes are kind of
a silly idea now if you test positive in
another country
and you can't get back to the us and
because you've tested positive
testing may not be accurate for a long
period of time
in that situation it makes sense to say
i believe this individual has recovered
they should be allowed to go back to the
u.s that that makes sense to me
if you have as a policy to come to
indoor restaurants you got to be
vaccinated or to go to movie theaters
you've got to be vaccinated vaccinated
or recovery certificate
doesn't seem like a very good idea
particularly since we don't really know
that much particularly in the context of
omicron for how long are you protected
after recovery we just don't know the
answers to those questions it seems
problematic to me uh and so
her whole goal here
was
let me get sick to get better to be
recovered to then be able to go places
without being vaccinated even the
pretext of that even that as a pretext
does not seem logical to me but another
tragic story uh unvaccinated person says
i'm gonna go and get myself sick in
order to recover and have immunity
it didn't work she is dead and we will
have more on this on our instagram you
can find that at davidpakmanshow on
instagram
you can also find me there at
david.pacman
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show it's great
to have back on the program today
vincent racanello who's a virology
professor at columbia university and
also host of this week in virology uh
great to have you back i really
appreciate it oh great to be here so i i
mean i guess we have to start with
omicron and uh the
if whatever prediction you want on
omicron you can find it which is this is
the beginning of something that's going
to get much worse this is the beginning
of the end of the pandemic and
everything in in between
what do we know now about
the level of transmissibility of omicron
in terms of its r value as well as how
much more or less likely it is to cause
hospitalization
so
determining transmissibility is very
difficult so getting of our value
especially this far into an epidemic is
very hard
but i like to look at what we call
secondary attack rates
which are calculated
in closed situation like a household yes
where you can know that this person was
infected and then within a certain
amount of time these other people got
infected
and it's not easy to do that but
recently a pre-print came out of denmark
where they did it and the beauty of the
study was it was just when they were
transitioning from delta to omicron
so you had
households that were either an omicron
household or a delta household it was
right perfect perfect and they had good
numbers and they have a terrific
medical records registry there so they
could get all the information and what
was very clear
is that omicron has a higher secondary
attack rate than delta so it's
transmitting better in the household
situation but that appears to be
entirely due to the fact that omicron is
evading antibodies
because as you know it has many changes
in the spike protein more than any other
variant and if you take sierra from
people who have been vaccinated or
recovered from infection it doesn't
block infection with omicron as well as
say with delta and so
the danish scientists concluded that
this increased ability of omicron to
transmit say within households is
entirely due to immune evasion and not
to an inherent increased
transmissibility of the virus so we
imagine that there are some properties
of viruses that can make them transmit
better maybe they reproduce better
they're more stable in droplets that
come out of your respiratory tract but
that's not the case with omicron it
really is evading
antibodies and that's why it's spreading
now the other part of your question how
about disease right now with first
reports out of south africa suggested
it might be milder and people started to
call it an army cold which is not really
right my colleague daniel griffin an
infectious disease doctor says that's
not right because he's seen plenty of
very sick people uh infected with
omicron and especially unvaccinated
people so in the unvaccinated omicron
can be just as severe as delta and
previous variants but the south african
study was kind of complicated because a
lot of the people in their study were
vaccinated and a lot of them were
younger and a lot of them didn't have
comorbidities and so that all biases it
to be milder so you know making
conclusions very quickly about
how severe infections are is very
difficult so i would say at this point
we know that omicron can evade immunity
and that's why it moves through a
population well
it can infect vaccinated people just
like delta could but in a vaccinated
person the disease is much milder than
an unvaccinated person with there's so
many things that we could go off to
from there just a couple so if we look
at the uk as an example a layperson
might look at cases and deaths and of
course at this point we know that not
nearly all of the infections are being
captured as a case which depends on a
test but putting that aside for a moment
it looked like during the omicron wave
cases went up about 6x in the uk
uh known cases whereas deaths went up
somewhere between 80 and 100 percent or
so
when you see that it suggests that it is
in some way
less likely to kill people and that's uk
not south africa but is are those two
numbers alone not enough to really tell
us that well the problem is that a lot
of the people are
vacs are vaccinated and that if you
stratify the data yes vaccinated versus
unvaccinated make sure you control for
age and comorbidities which is not easy
to do true uh then
you find that in it's milder in
vaccinated people but so is delta and so
are all the other variants but the fact
is that vaccination works
it prevents you from getting severe
disease and now part of the issue is
with omicron it came at about the
holiday season right when everyone is
traveling and getting together plus we
are now getting together way more than
we ever did since the beginning of the
pandemic because people are starting to
relax and all of this contributes so you
know movement of a virus has many
factors around it not just the virus not
just your immunity but how people behave
as well
the um wastewater data in some cities in
the united states is showing just
dramatic reductions in the amount of a
virus during this omicron wave i think
when i looked
10 days ago or so or maybe a week ago at
boston wastewater data it was down about
two-thirds even though cases are only
down about 10 percent which which you
know you would imagine that that would
be a
cases would be a lagging indicator to
the wastewater how important is the
wastewater data
i'm not sure you can you can quantify
anything all you can say is we have this
virus here now so there may be a period
where you don't see a virus in
wastewater or the levels are very low
and then suddenly you get more positive
so that can inform you of an impending
epidemic but i would not make much of
the levels because you know this is this
is incidental virus that you're
swallowing it's passing out of your
gastrointestinal tract and going into
the sewer so
it's not really part of the infection
process
so so to ascribe any meaning to how much
is there remember it's we're doing pcr
to measure viral rna in the water and as
a recent study out of switzerland just
showed there is
very little correlation between pcr
levels and infectious virus so i think
you have to be you have to realize the
limitations of looking at virus rna in
wastewater that's fair that's fair
last time you were on we talked a little
bit about the very top level
understanding that we have about viruses
over time
becoming less deadly and you gave us
many caveats when we talked about that
but it was this sort of general idea in
the last few weeks
as the conversation about what happens
after omicron has become a more and more
relevant conversation there have been a
bunch of different articles coming out
claiming to debunk that idea as a
general principle that really viruses
become
more chaotic and that that could get you
a
milder disease but it might not and that
there are counter examples from history
can we now
because it seems more relevant than ever
talk a little more specifically about
this idea of what is likely to come next
after omicron
so the idea which we talked about last
time you know it's a it's a human idea
that viruses over time
tend to get less virulent but we're
talking about long long periods of time
we're not talking about two years here
ah so for example if a virus spilled and
remember all human viruses came from
some other animal at some point in time
let's say thousands of years ago tens of
thousands of years ago
measles virus 15 000 years ago spilled
over into people from cows right and so
initially it's probably quite lethal
because it's a new host we have no
immunity to the virus and it does what
soros cov2 does but over time population
immunity grows and that helps you have
more a milder disease when you get
infected now
there's also this hypothesis that maybe
the virus changes over time because
there's no point in
killing your host or making your host
very sick
so random changes in the genome that
reduce
virulence may persist but i have to say
you know with the one exception that we
might have talked about last time using
viruses to kill rabbits in australia
there's no other evidence that
viruses tend to get less virulent over
time in their house it's just an
appealing hypothesis so the australian
situation they had brought in rabbits in
the 1800s for hunting purposes they
opened they multiplied like crazy there
were too many of them so they introduced
a virus to try and kill them and in the
first year
99 of the rabbits were killed but then
those those one percent that survived
were more resistant to the virus and
then the virus changed to be less
virulent as well so it's actually a
beautiful experiment that's consistent
with this idea but i must say there's no
other evidence for it and as you
mentioned as soon as omicron came out we
had these data from south africa
people were saying oh it's getting less
virulent but i i think it's far too
premature to say that because as we've
already talked about there are lots of
confounding factors there
so what does that do for the
conversation about what what is next and
whether we are months from shifting from
the pandemic to the endemic phase of
this is it do can we really say anything
about that at this point
well from the start we have thought that
as population immunity grew to this
virus we would have
less and less severe disease and we see
that in vaccinated people it supports
that even though we have many variants
emerging that can evade immunity to a
certain extent the vaccines still work
they protect you from severe disease and
hospitalization really in the 90s
percent still so
and we know from other coronaviruses the
common cold coronaviruses that infect
all of us every year
that widespread population immunity
probably associates with milder disease
and so that from the very start
led to this idea that over time as more
of the world became immune to osaurus
cov2
we would have less and less severe
disease the virus would not necessarily
be changing with respect to virulence
but simply population immunity would do
that i really think that's what's going
to happen because we see the vaccines
working really well
despite the the energetic evolution of
the virus so i've always thought and
this was actually
an idea influenced by ralph barrack who
was a corota virologist for many years
he said
this will probably be a common cold
coronavirus who knows how long it will
take
and at that point we might not need to
vaccinate it against it any longer we're
not at that point yet though i don't
think we are because you know most of
the world is still not fully vaccinated
right right
there are some countries that have very
high rates of vaccination and they have
much less disease
as a consequence but there are other
countries like africa which is which are
barely vaccinated so we can't hope to
end a pandemic until we get
either a lot of people infected or
vaccinated i mean that's what's going to
happen now over the next few years
you're going to either get vaccinated or
you're going to get infected in in both
cases you're going to get some kind of
immunity
there are a few countries at least a
couple the uk
australia that are pretty quickly going
in a direction of saying
uh we are we believe we are functioning
as though we are in the endemic phase we
are going to start removing restrictions
and kind of putting this at the
individual level to say if if i have a
particular reason that i need to go
beyond what's required of me by by the
state i'm going to do it based on my
level of risk does that make any sense
to you at this point in time it does and
i've been thinking about this for now
many weeks because we it's very clear we
have multiple vaccines that work
they don't prevent infection which is
normal but they do prevent severe
disease and so in many countries like
the uk and israel and the us where we
have plenty of vaccine
we now have vaccines that can control
severe disease people who have decided
not to be vaccinated have made their
choice so i think the rest of the
population can now start to move on the
only problem
with that idea
is that if too many unvaccinated people
get infected as you know the health care
system gets overburdened yes and
that is a problem because they have
other issues to deal with they have
other health problems in patients to
deal with so we don't want hospitals
full of unvaccinated severely ill
covered patients that's why i think in
many places in the u.s we're still
masking even though we're all fully
vaccinated many of us are fully
vaccinated
there's no risk to us anymore of of
getting severely ill we are protecting
the unvaccinated the biggest and most
regular pushback that i hear when
anybody says what you just said is but
hold on a second even the people doing
everything
correctly getting their three doses and
etc
they are still at greater risk due to
the unvaccinated because of the ability
to spread the disease the counter that's
incred increasingly being placed upon us
is well hold on a second
with omicron it's not clear that the
vaccines prevent transmission they
prevent death they prevent serious
illness but but do they really prevent
transmission so it's really a two-part
question what about the people saying
even those who did the right things we
are still at risk because of everybody
else and number two what do we know
about the effect of the vaccine on
transmission right now
so the i feel i am not at risk
from an unvaccinated person okay because
i am triple vaccinated and if i get
infected which i likely will
uh i will have a mild disease right
there's a very good chance i have a mild
disease most of the severe disease
in unvex and vaccinated people
you know that 10 percent or so that are
in people with comorbidities either
they're they're older or they're obese
that's a big one or diabetic or
asthmatic
those are the people who get are most
likely to have severe disease even if
fully vaccinated of course we don't want
to forget the kids under five who can't
be vaccinated yet we still have to be
careful about them so i don't view
vaccinated people as the ones at risk
it's the unvaccinated people and they're
the ones that are going to cause
problems in the health care system
now with respect to transmission
there was a wonderful pre-print out of
switzerland last week
and this complements other work that
that's come out as well which clearly
shows that well first of all you can't
measure
transmission by doing pcr
that is very clear and almost every
study that has looked at
shedding of a vaccinated person is wrong
because they're measuring pcr and that
does not correlate with infectious virus
shedding in the swiss study they showed
that a vaccinated person not only sheds
less infectious virus than an
unvaccinated person but does so for
fewer days after being infected okay and
so that has significant implications so
vaccination doesn't abolish shedding it
doesn't abolish transmission but it
knocks it so far down that it no longer
plays a role in driving uh the epidemic
that's so that that seems to then
support those who say i'm vaccinated but
the unvaccinated are putting me at risk
i know statistically you still won't be
seriously ill but a lot of people have
comorbidities in this country it sounds
like it's not wrong to say even as a
vaccinated person the unvaccinated do
put me at greater risk
no the the unvaccinated do not because
you are not going to get sick right if
you're fully vaccinated the likelihood
you're going to get severely ill is very
low oh i see it so it's both it's both
that the by being by being unvaccinated
you are shedding more virus but by being
vaccinated you also are less likely to
actually get sick exactly okay you are
less likely to pass it on to someone
else as well so the more people we have
vaccinated the more likely we can stop
the transmission
uh very that's we we are going to link
to that uh pre-print from switzerland it
sounds like there's really a wealth of a
wealth wealth of data there we've been
speaking with vincent racanello virology
professor at columbia university and
make sure to check out this week in
virology always great having you on
thank you for having me david appreciate
it
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
so yesterday president joe biden held
his first what's called a formal press
conference in
uh several months and i'm not going to
go through
each piece of it because quite frankly
most of it wasn't very interesting
i do think the incredible double
standard applied by many right-wingers
on these press conferences should be
mentioned which is for months and months
they were saying where's biden no formal
press conference he did one yesterday
the press wouldn't stop asking questions
and so biden kept going and going for
nearly two hours and then they said he
was droning on it was a marathon press
conference nearly two hours he talked
way too long guys you can't have it both
ways but the piece that i want to focus
on and i apologize in advance for those
who
saw this yesterday and have already
suffered brain damage from seeing it um
i'm going to play for you maybe the
dumbest question i have heard in the
history of journalism and i know that
that says a lot
certainly this is the dumbest question
asked of joe biden during his presidency
the person asking the question is fox
news reporter peter ducey
peter ducey is always trying to get
gotchas and so on and so forth joe biden
knows this and yet he calls on him
basically every time i i only remember a
few instances
uh
like this specifically
where um joe biden has called on peter
ducey every single time doesn't shy away
from his questions listen to the
question that peter ducey asked why are
you trying so hard in your first year to
pull the country so far to the left
[Laughter]
all right let's let joe biden first
start to answer it then i i have a lot
to say about this
well
i'm not
i don't know what you consider to be too
far to the left if in fact we're talking
about
making sure that we had the money for
coven making sure we had the money to
put together the bipartisan
infrastructure making sure we were able
to provide for those things that in fact
would significantly reduce the burden on
working-class people but make them they
have to continue to work hard i don't
know how that is pointed to the left if
you may recall so okay so joe biden
hasn't has an answer for it
the reason that this question is so dumb
is because
the narrative around biden's extreme
leftism
is so untrue
that the the left wishes this was the
case like i wish joe biden was doing
more left-wing stuff think about biden's
major actions during his first year as
president and this is not like a report
card it's just evaluating whether the
things he did are really left or not
he did covet stimulus now trump did two
of them biden's covet stimulus is no
further left than trump's two covid
biden did one trump did too so that's a
major accomplishment he did it
relatively quickly once getting in
office not very far left number two
the vaccine rollout has been one of joe
biden's kind of major actions or pro
programs during his first year
um if you believe trump made the
vaccines which he didn't but let's
imagine that we we kind of uh accept
this right-wing story that that trump
made the vaccines
how is distributing the vaccines that
your republican hero made far left so
that that's not far left
um joe biden got a very modest
infrastructure bill passed and remember
that for a very long time republicans
liked infrastructure spending to some
degree and there's nothing particularly
far left about it you know center
centrist governments around the world do
infrastructure
right-wing governments around the world
do infrastructure left-wing governments
around the world do infrastructure it's
a very modest
infrastructure bill quite milk toast if
i say so myself
getting out of afghanistan is a major
first-year biden accomplishment that was
a trump plan
so how is biden doing the thing
that trump promised to do
far left not seeing anything that
matches that description these are the
major biden accomplishments during year
one
now just rolling out sending four free
coveted tests to anybody who asks for
them
but you've got to ask for them
there is nothing very far left here and
a lot of this so so there's really two
stories here one story is the false
narrative about biden being an extreme
leftist i think that biden ran on a
policy that's like marginally to the
left of barack obama and certainly the
implementation has been extraordinarily
center-left
nothing remarkable at all
and then it's just this pathetic and
flaccid
continued
uh attempt from peter ducey to make
himself seem alpha for lack of a better
term and do a big boy for the fox news
audience which i think is kind of
working for him like i think if the fox
audience sees why are you trying to move
the country so far to the left they
probably do believe that that's what joe
biden is trying to do even though it
could not be further from the truth i am
having a hard time and i know newsmax
and oan
sometimes ask questions of presidents
this seems like the dumbest question uh
posed to a president in a very very long
time
the other part i want to talk about of
joe biden's uh press conference
yesterday remember joe biden
criticized by the right for not doing a
press conference for a while did one
yesterday and took questions for nearly
two hours and some right-wingers were
saying he went on too long the drudge
report had a splash headline about
marathon press conference
he doesn't do one and you criticize him
and then he he answers too many
questions and then you criticize give me
a break guys one person who was
extraordinarily triggered by joe biden's
press conference yesterday and i think
it's both what was in the press
conference and the fact that it's joe
biden doing a press conference
rather than him is donald trump donald
trump putting out a statement yesterday
through his save america thing
and what he said was how come biden
picks a reporter off a list
in all cases softball questions and then
reads the answer i would never have been
allowed to get away with that nor would
i have to
then donald trump appearing with fox
news host and a radio host i don't
remember if it's westwood one or where
mark levin hosts his show right wing
host mark levin and trump is just
completely triggered by the fact that
people paid attention to joe biden let's
take a listen i noticed that i noticed a
lot of things i noticed uh things that
are affecting the american people
directly um it thinks things are going
pretty swimmingly they didn't talk about
crime
they didn't talk about what's going on
in the classrooms they didn't talk about
what's happening at the border
um and he was there for almost two hours
and none of that came up don't you find
that remarkable
well crime is so bad it's so out of
control when you look at these
kids being shoved off subway stations in
new york of platforms right into a train
now that that's horrible
what on earth does that have to do with
joe biden that it's it's we're talking
about nypd like what they on the one
hand they say
let states and municipalities do what's
right for them
but it's joe biden's fault
that something is happening on the
subways of new york it's tragic but what
does it have to do with joe biden in
full speed and
a young
woman's thrown right into the train
right into the face so as you can hear
by the way this is downer trump right
now very very down low energy the train
killed instantly and
then you look at what happened with the
young lady selling
in a furniture store selling furniture
and somebody walks in and knifes her to
death horrible and
nothing happens to these people
nothing happens and the other question
here of course when we talk about
violence in cities is
they talk about
dangerous democratic democratic-run
cities
as many of you know because i've done
this so many times most cities are done
by democrat run by democrats because
more democrats want to live in cities
and republicans tend to live more
rurally so really safe cities are run by
democrats and higher crime cities are
run by democrats because cities tend to
be run by democrats okay let's continue
trump angry with the reporters during
the press conference a
commander-in-chief saying that he
expects russia to invade ukraine
now don't you think vladimir putin heard
that too
well yeah and it was like
the problem is it was like nothing's
going to be done you know another word
yeah i expected now maybe it was a
mistake because it was said in the
middle of another sentence and another
thought
but he said use the words expects that
he's going in
and i thought that was strange whether
you
don't want it to happen or did you know
i just thought it was a very strange
thought to be putting out there that he
actually what great analysis from trump
huh text him to go in
and nobody seems to pick it up because
the reporters are the most friendly
group of reporters i've ever seen they
don't even ask questions they make
positive statements and then sit down
you know i really didn't see it that way
we i
we have
i i have been endlessly critical of uh
of of the press corps when trump was
president and when biden is president i
think there are often things managed by
the press corps in ways that i think
don't really make sense
uh but that was not what took place
yesterday there were real questions
asked of joe biden biden sometimes
didn't even answer them biden was asked
straight up what happened to canceling
10 grand in student debt he literally
never answered the question he walked
off wasn't wasn't pressed on it so i
have my criticisms of biden of report
but it was not a friendly press
conference in the way trump is
describing here whatsoever
um
here's more of uh trump on the press
conference patriots it's a great honor
to have with us this is from the start
of the interview
president donald trump president trump
how are you sir hello mark how are you
i'm doing great president trump
i imagine you saw most of this press
conference and no i did
and joe biden said he's had enormous
progress during his presidency i don't
see it that way to you
well progress in destroying our country
yes i think that's been tremendous
uh i also said something that i assume
was a mistake but
he said he expects putin to go in he
said
uh i expect him to go in
to go into ukraine and i thought that
was a very unusual answer i don't know
if he knew what he was saying because it
was
he said that as part of another question
and he was a little confused because he
tried to correct something yeah that's
part of the biden dementia narrative
which trump continues to push and then
of course at some point it must be
mentioned that joe biden is pushing us
towards communism
uh and that did come up of course as
absurd as it is
you know joe bond says he's not moved to
the left peter ducey said to him
why are you trying to take the country
to the left he says i'm a moderate i'm
not a socialist i'm not bernie sanders
i think his actions defy that don't they
well he says all that he said that
during the debates he said that during
his debates with other democrats and of
course it's true joe biden has not moved
us towards socialism or communism and i
would encourage anybody who believes
that he has to explain exactly which
policies have done so
but it's not true
and you know what he said on energy
you look at what he said on energy look
at what you take a look at religion
what's going on there you nothing
you know the stance is that these
democrats i mean quite literally nothing
is going on radical left democrats are
taking
uh
no he said all of these things that that
were very moderate and then
he
did things that nobody could believe
bernie sanders cannot believe what's
happening
he said yes bernie is like oh my god
joe you're so far left i can't believe
it i would have never gotten away with
any of this stuff
it's uh it's not
it's not really even believable mark
what's happening to me so trump audibly
confused and again look at biden's
actions tell me which ones are the
socialist communist ones he did covet
stimulus but trump did two of them he
rolled out the vaccine that republicans
believe trump made that's not very far
left he passed a very modest
infrastructure bill and he got out of
afghanistan which was trump's plan
so uh if any time anybody says to you
remember when jesse lee peterson
interviewed me in la
um when obama was president
he or no i think no trump was president
but it was about what barack obama did
he said obama was a socialist and i was
like well what did he do and he's like
well he gave some people cell phones
uh that was jesse lee peterson's
explanation so when people say biden is
going socialist communist ask
specifically
which policies are the socialistic
communistic policies i'm curious to see
what people tell you we have a voicemail
number that number is 219 to david p
here's a voicemail i received with a
very practical question about if it came
time to leave the country would you
still be able to leave the country it's
a very good question
hi david i just heard you say on the
stream that if the united states becomes
a full-blown dictatorship by
2024 yeah you will be leaving the
country so i've been thinking about this
a lot myself and
is it too late
if you wait until it's a full-blown
dictatorship will you even be able to
leave this country if you're that
concerned about it happening should you
be making plans to leave before it goes
full-blown dictatorship yeah this is a
fair question which is like if things
completely changed overnight in the u.s
and all of a sudden no one was allowed
to leave the plan of saying i will stay
if and until it gets really bad
doesn't work because if it got so bad
you wouldn't be allowed to leave i don't
you know when we talk about the canadian
political scientists who said the u.s
could be a dictatorship by 2030 or
whatever else the case may be
i believe that will it would be a
continued slow slide in that direction
and i am counting on the the belief
that i would have time to get out if
such a time came now would i if it's so
slow that the frog doesn't realize it's
getting burned right
would i know when it's time to leave
these are all fair questions but i don't
think it would be like an overnight no
more flights out i just don't think that
that's the case uh but maybe some people
in the audience uh have a different
perspective on the bonus show today
we will talk about the 5g airline
kerfuffle that's going on we'll explain
it and talk about what's going on
new mexico has an interesting approach
to all of the teachers out sick with
omicron they're bringing in the national
guard to teach very interesting
and a louisiana senate candidate has
gone viral for smoking cannabis in a
campaign ad we will tell you uh who it
is and why he did it and what the effect
is going to be on the campaign all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at
joinpacman.com get instant access and i
will see you then